[Music]
he
a
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them jingle bells jingle bells Trump
smells and hard to know that that
[__] stinks
[Music]
right the [__] Big Macs buckets of
fried
chicken those got to produce some nasty
[__] diapers right I mean come
on come
on babies have the shittiest smelling
diapers but I would imagine that Trump
is probably the champion the champion of
smelly ass diapers he's also he would
win that competition and and he's
winning the competition on the 14th
Amendment like I said he
would
I I honestly don't want to say I Told
You So in this instance but I'm going to
sit here and say it and it's it's a very
unpopular opinion amongst my
peers because it feels
good to take Trump off a
ballot I I I it feels good to some
people to use our democracy to undermine
it it's what you're doing okay and I I
get this all the time with this opinion
people message me they comment Tony 14th
section three makes it clear no it
doesn't that's the point if it made it
clear this wouldn't be a
question
okay and by the way by the way I would
love if these 14th amends
would bring the same
energy of people they could actually
14th Coy Griffin was a county
commissioner in New Mexico he was he was
found guilty of participating in the
January 6th Insurrection and a federal
judge took his ass out of office he held
an elected office he wasn't on a ballot
wasn't trying to get on a primary ballot
he held an
office it was the actual point of the
14th
Amendment the people who framed
it actually meant it that way because
there
were insurrectionist and traitors who
held seats that they needed the
14th because they were [__] traitors
to the Constitution and their oath now
we all know what Trump has done he did
it in front of our eyes but that's not
the law that that's not the law you
don't get to decide that's how it
[__] works cuz Justice
matters Justice doesn't matter if it's
just a [__] Pitchfork mob wanting
someone
gone okay that's not that's not what
that's not what matters in Justice it's
not and just because you got your
pitchforks for one [__] you
should bring the energy for all the
other [__] cuz there are listen
listen to me listen to me I don't know
if you know this I don't know of you
know this but there are a lot of January
six insurrectionist who went to the
capital that day because he ordered them
to to go [__] hang my Pence and
overturn your vote who were running in
your school boards in your county
Commissions in your state houses your
state senates in United States
Congressional seats they're running and
they're on ballots and these 14th and
members are doing
nothing because it's not about the
principle it's not about the
Constitution to them it's Trump
derangement
syndrome listen folks we can [__]
beat this [__] oh my God we are
going to [__] crush this [__]
fascist Grandpa Hitler wannabe
[__] we're going to crush him
Crush
him we don't need some [__] lame ass
excuse to beat him and I get this oh but
Tony we can do two things at once
Americans
can't that that's that's a [__] lie
and you know it you know you know that
we can't do two things at once it's not
a
thing we we get to have one [__]
narrative one only one [__] narrative
folks that's all we get that's all we
get one you don't get two narratives you
don't get to have two competing
narratives that's why they lose see
that's why Trump is such a [__] loser
that's why MAA sucks ass because they
try to
have narratives all over the [__]
map when he says [__] like I didn't say
I want to be a dictator I just said I
want to be a
dictator those are two different
narratives that's why he'll lose you see
you can't have two you can only have one
that will win that's how elections work
that's how politics work that's how
Americans
work it's how it works rather you like
it or you don't that's how it [__]
works and most people are not paying
attention
to this 14th Amendment thing they're not
paying attention to who's running they
don't even know that Nikki Haley Ronda
santis Chris Christie and radama
dingdong is running against Trump they
have no idea they don't know they can
tell you all the stats from their
fantasy football league they can tell
you that [__] they got that right there
in the Forefront of their
mind most Americans aren't running
around paying attention to politics like
you are like I do they don't that's why
I try to do this show the way I do it so
that it's not all
[__] welcome welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast today we are going to
break down the data and the polls from
last week get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense no one wants to hear that
[__] that way they
don't we got to get people to pay
attention and when we get them to pay
attention we get one shot at it one just
[__]
one at the narrative that's it and
they're doing a bang up job of of giving
us the narrative that will absolutely
[__] crush them Revenge are you
kidding me this guy this guy post out a
goddamn word map of Revenge and he's
like yeah you're goddamn right I want
revenge
how can't you see this this is like do
you remember do you remember the second
Ninja Turtles movie from the 90s Secret
of the Ooze right Secret of the Ooze and
it's it's Shredder right everyone thinks
he's dead because he got crushed in the
[__] garbage truck because he's a
piece of trash right we crushed him in
2020 we crushed Shredder with the
garbage truck right ah we crushed him
he's gone but then in the second movie
in the secret of the Ooze Shredder's
hand comes out of the landfill and he
five he wants
revenge that's his
platform that that's what he's selling
the American people they're like okay so
what are you gon to do about Healthcare
Revenge what are you gonna what are you
going to do about prices of groceries
huh what are you g what's what's your
power
okay how about how about how about Fuel
and natural resources how about that
what's your policy
huh all right all right what what about
what about foreign policy what's your
foreign policy I mean if you had one
what would it be
Revenge H
interesting and he's not talking about
revenge on our enemies of the country
he's talking about re revenge on
Americans folks that's his policy he's
saying it out loud Grandpa Hitler's like
yeah I want to be a dictator and yeah
I'm gonna get revenge on you because you
didn't elect me in 2020 because let's
let's be let's be really serious about
this the one silver lining that I have
found because I've tried I've tried and
tried and tried and tried to find a
silver lining in this 14th Amendment
nonsense I've tried really have worked
hard at trying and I found one silver
lining only
one there is a silver lining behind it
though I'll give you that I'll give you
that all the people yelling screaming at
me that I'm wrong and Tony he's gonna be
taking off ballots blah blah blah yakity
schacky no he's
not I'm gonna I'm gonna be right okay
just trust me on this I mean you can
doubt me that's what we do here we want
descent in our democracy
but just trust me on this doubt me if
you want there is one silver lining this
whole 14th Amendment thing is that this
idea that Democrats rigged the entire
2020 election with no one knowing not a
[__] soul but a couple you know
right-wingers like Steve Bannon and
denes duza and Trump those are the only
people that know that Democrats cheated
right but they can't keep him off
[__] primary ballot are you [__]
me this should be a slam dunk this
should be [__] easy I mean if we rig
2020 can't we [__] fat [__] off a
ballot come on man this proves this
proves the point that it's all
[__] rigging of the 2020 election so
I'll give you that silver
lining if you want that still minining
and maybe if you feel good about the
14th thing which you shouldn't but if
you feel good about it maybe that's one
thing you can go take with you and go
type into the social medias or tell your
friends and your family that there's no
[__] way that the Democrats rigged
the 2020 election if they can't keep
Grandpa Hitler off primary ballots
okay not a thing not a thing and it only
proves even further that our election
system is actually
sound and that's what I mean by the
Silver Lining because a lot of people
don't understand that you can't really
rig a federal
election you can't you can't really rig
it because there's no central place
where the election
happens yeah that's right your local
counties run the
election your local counties run the
election
do you know how many counties there are
in the United States I I I don't know
personally I I haven't Googled it yet
but there's a lot there's a lot of
counties a lot of
counties and you would have to go around
to every single [__] County and
convince every single [__] official
to participate in this election stealing
thing
right that's the trouble that the the
the 14th amend amendments are having
here is they got to go state by state by
state because they're just trying to
keep him off the primary ballot right
now because that's the question that's
the question in hand now when he wins
the nomination they'll have to start the
process all over again it's a thing in
court when it happens you got to go to
court so they got to start the process
all over again in these states when he
gets on the general election
ballot you see you see because the
states the States run the elections but
really the county governments run the
elections they have the polling
stations they give you your little
[__] card that you have here's your
voter ID card your voter registration
you register at the county a lot of
times because of your address kind of
funny how that works go ask Mark Meadows
how that works out when you uh register
your address in a certain
County oh boy but you know don't listen
to Tony it's okay it's all right it's
all right another bone I wanna I just
I'm just gonna [__] in your cereal today
I know you want me to say I everyone and
really honestly I think it's getting to
the point to where people come here
because they know I'm not just going to
[__] and feed [__] that they want to
hear like I think there's a whole group
of people here that do not like some of
the stuff I say but they're like at
least Tony will tell me the [__]
truth at least he'll [__] just say it
he won't [__] hide it or try to keep
me happy so I'll keep watching that way
he can keep
grifting okay like I'm not just going to
tell you this [__] because you want to
hear
it
that's not why you're here it's not why
I'm here at least I don't know I I mean
some of you might be here for different
reasons some of you it might be my good
looks some of you it might be
because I have the opinion that you have
in most
cases and a lot of you might just
[__] hate me or love to hate me I
guess if you want to put it that way but
I'm not gonna sugarcoat [__]
especially when it has to do with our
democracy and the [__] future of it
either I'm not gonna I'm not going to
sit around and [__] you just so
you'll [__] listen just so I'll get
views just so everyone feels good
everyone feels great about the current
situation listen the [__] on
fire and Grandpa Hitler Wants Revenge
okay pretty simple but Jack Smith I got
a bone to pick with Jack Smith now
[Laughter]
people like oh Tony Tony see Jack Smith
you were wrong Jack Smith is GNA go to
the Supreme Court about the immunity and
the Supreme Court says [__] you follow
the
rules I said that I said that when it
happened I said why is Jack Smith not
trying to follow the [__]
rules why is he trying to change the
rules he's trying to jump over the
appeals court
because he wants that March 4th
date because he's going to save the
country H is not his [__] job to save
our country that is not Jack Smith's job
folks it is not and it shouldn't
be his job is to
prosecute the January 6
case and I believe that if he has
evidence that he should do a superseding
indictment that includes Congress people
and Senate
and Trump staff he should do that [__]
this you got to go to court before the
election
[__] it's enough of that stuff we are
going to lose and we are going to keep
losing if people don't do the right
thing and the right thing here to do is
to prosecute that case yes it's very
unpopular of
me to say Jack Smith is doing it wrong
it's very unpopular of
me but I'm not here to win a popularity
contest honestly I don't give a [__] I
I'm I'm here to tell you about our
democracy I'm here to lay it out of how
it can and could happen and I don't
idolize Jack Smith I don't think Jack
Smith is
infallible okay and I believe he's
making big
mistakes big huge mistakes that are
going to backfire
that's what I believe because I think
that Jack Smith is doing it for the
wrong reasons he's not doing it to
prosecute the case he should that's what
he should do that's what he should do he
should [__] do that whatever it
takes to do
that whatever it takes uh some uh
someone V in the Discord says ain't no
one losing around here here bro Tony
said what laugh out loud please just
listen to the professionals the
professionals hey how how is it working
out listening to the
professionals how's that working out for
you huh how often are they
right even in the Colorado case on this
14th Amendment because I know that's
what they're talking
about even even in the Colorado
case they didn't even really make it if
you really read it if you really read
the decision which I did I went and I
read it I didn't just listen to Glen
2000 I used to be Glenn 2 now it's Glenn
2000 he's GNA come after me
eventually I don't just listen I go read
it and if you read it what they really
said was hey we want to make a decision
but we really don't want to we want the
Supreme Court to make the decision so
here here you go here Supreme Court you
make the decision is really what they
said that was your
win and you're going to lose that one
that's right I said it Supreme Court is
going to rule in Trump's
favor I'm calling it they're going to
rule in Trump's favor and it's going to
be another win for Trump and another
loss for what for what because because
you you you are you don't trust them
voters are you [__] [__] me get
the [__] out of here with that
nonsense I trust this country look since
2018 since 2018 we have kicked manga's
ass and we have kicked their ass more
and more and more every single [__]
time and they Double Down and trible
Down Jesus Christ the guy is saying I
want revenge and I want to be a dictator
right into the back of a garbage
truck thank you Grandpa
Hitler the
shredder as some might call him on a
1990s
recall back to a
movie it's it's going to
be it's going to be
a very very intense
year it's going to
continue to be intense around this
election and we got one shot one shot at
the narrative because that's what
matters when you're talking about
elections only one only one narrative
you don't want you don't want any other
Nar narrative leaking out beyond the
boundaries you really
don't because once those narratives take
hold it's really [__] difficult to
undo
them and
folks his narrative is Revenge and
election
interference that's it they stole the
election they're trying to steal this
one I want revenge that's his
narrative and you're giving him his
narrative you're giving it to him you're
handing it over to him cuz why you're
scared of
him we are not scared of
him I am not scared of him I know you
aren't scared of him why in the [__] are
we standing around act like we're scared
of this fat
[__] are you kidding me I'm I I
welcome welcome the [__] ass kicking
that he's about to
receive in this
election I am
welcoming the ass kicking that manga is
going to receive in this election
because they're doubling down on
authoritarianism and wanting him to be
the dictator and they're cheering for
him to get revenge on
Americans are you [__] serious and
you don't think we can beat that come on
get the [__] out of here there is no
reason for us to play into their
narrative at all and to be honest with
you if all the left and all the all
the all my colleagues on the left the
commentators if you want to call them
that they're not really commentators if
you want to know the honest truth when
they're saying [__] like they're saying
about the
14th you're not really commentating
you're [__] just telling everyone
what they want to
hear that's not commentating I hate to
tell you that it's not it it's not
commentating when you just say what
everyone wants to hear that's what MAA
does that's what qanan does that's what
Trump does they just say whatever they
[__] want to he it's what the santis
does it's what Nikki haly does it's what
rad damama dingdong does pronounce my
name
correctly they
just
they just say what these people want to
hear that's not
commentary it's
not it's it's just telling you what you
want to hear so you'll buy something
you'll buy Trump gold or you'll buy a a
land in Scotland or some stupid
[__] oh
[__] and that's why you come here here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday unless it's a holiday week like
this week it's a holiday week so we're
on Wednesday Thursday Friday this week
three days and then we got the New
Year's holiday over the weekend so next
week will be Wednesday Thursday Friday
next week and then we'll be back on a
regular schedule I promise cross my
heart and hope to
die oh we will be back on a regular
schedule after next week again that is
my big announcement
is that we have three days this week
three days next week so we'll be off
Monday and
Tuesday um for next week but today I
have a a guest with me today he could
not he usually comes on Thursdays and it
was supposed to be last Thursday but we
know it was Christmas and he can't come
tomorrow so I've got Cliff Sher with me
today on Wednesday it's kind of weird
but we're gonna have him here I know
he's usually here on Thursdays we're
going to have him here today and I I bet
we dis agree on this 14th and I bet we
agree a little bit what do you think do
you think because I kind of feel like I
talk cliff into come in my direction on
the Liz Cheney thing a little bit maybe
maybe just I don't know I don't know
Cliff's position exactly on this 14th
thing that's the beautiful part about
democracy it's the beautiful part about
conversations is we can have them we can
do it we can do it and we're going to do
it right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast today and and I also want to
thank every single one of you for all
the wishes that you sent me and my
family over the holidays there were so
many people who sent me private messages
who commented um who sent us warm wishes
and I really I want to tell you thank
you and merry Christmas and happy
holidays I hope we go into this New Year
kicking ass and taking [__] names
because we're going to have to to save
this democracy it is important that we
have one narrative that we March behind
that narrative and it is democracy
over
autocracy that's what it is that's what
it's going to be right here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific as soon as
we're back from the New Year holidays in
2024 I love you don't go anywhere don't
go anywhere Cliff sheor going to join us
right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza Magic
eat pepperoni hugs spot Pizza your tummy
say thank you your mouth say h pepperoni
hugs spot it's like family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thee Tony Michaels we're back
to the king of Brilliance this is the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
oh I'm
muted do you guys like the uh call back
sorry I I was trying to fix my my mic
some people are saying it was cracking
um is is it cracking is it
cracking is it still cracking yeah I
know I I was muted for a second I was
trying to I was trying to get my mic um
fixed I was trying to get it fixed it it
yes it was I think I got it fixed I
think I got it fixed seems okay now
they're saying so I had I had to turn it
off and and I didn't get it all the way
back on it's okay it's okay it's all
right everything is fine I was asking
when I was muted because I was trying to
fix my mic if and that's see that's
that's what so what we do we go to
breaks and we try to fix those problem
in
breaks um like like Cliff is trying to
join now he's having a few issues but
he'll he'll be here he'll be here soon
don't worry don't worry don't
worry but I was saying do you like the
call back um from uh Ninja Turtles 2 is
it's actually not Ninja Turtles 2o It's
called Ninja Turtles Secret of the use
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Secret of
the use uh where Shredder comes back to
get his revenge a lot of people don't
like that one they don't like that one
yeah um but at the end of the movie he
actually takes the Ooze right that the
ninja Teenage we Ninja Turtles turn them
into the teenage mut Ninja Turtles and
he becomes Super Shredder s
Shredder and R say go ninja go ninja go
go go go go Ninja Goat that's like um
you know um Vanilla Ice was really hot
right at that time right like on fire
because of Ice Ice Ice
Baby uh and then they did the go ninja
go in that movie uh where Vanilla Ice
does the Go Ninja Go Ninja Go I mean
it's a I I like the movie of course you
know I grew up in the '90s and I love
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
so pazzi says that Joe Biden is Master
Splinter yeah that I mean if you want to
put it that way that could be it could
be I think that's I think that's a a
good a we got a good call back here with
the Secret of the
Ooze um in the teenage anent Mutant
Ninja Turtles we're going to get cliff
on here in just a second um he's still
having some
difficulties yeah I can't I can't see
you there Cliff yeah it might be might
be your camera
settings if you can hear
me but we we we'll get it figured out
here uh yeah he can hear me but I can't
see him and I don't know if his mic if
you want we can just bring you on you
just give me a thumbs up if you want to
bring you on and you can just you can
have your sound but everyone wants to
see your pretty
face they they're mad at me this morning
any not all of them some of them are my
side and I'm getting more and more
people over to my side about this 14th
Amendment stuff right I just have the UN
I just have the unpopular
opinion that I think it's a waste of
energy and it's a waste of time like we
only got a few we only got a few
[__] a few [__] months to get our
[__] together to beat him like that's
the thing is we really we really do only
have a few months we can't be wasting
our time on [__] like [__]
motions that Jack Smith's trying to file
so that they go ahead with the trial on
March 4th who gives us [__] if they punt
that trial I told you they were going to
punt that trial anyways I told you that
that trial was not going to happen on
March 4th I told you that that was the
expectation that I set because that is
the expectation that you should
have I love it I love it that people get
mad people get mad because I I use the
old thinky space to try to figure out
what the hell is going to happen and
then try to you know comment on what the
hell I think's going to
happen and then do
that again you're you're not going to
get the March 4th
trial and and the reason why I know that
is cuz Jack Smith is trying so hard to
get
it like so hard to
get the March 4 trial to kick off on
March 4th because he's so terrified that
this thing is gonna not kick off on
March 4th which it
isn't it
isn't I mean chuin is going to be fair
that's the one thing I do know and I've
said that from the very beginning when
chuin drew the straw for the DC trial
and I looked at chuan's history because
I didn't I didn't know who Jud chuckin
was like I wasn't familiar with her work
until she drew the straw for the DC
trial and then I went and looked and I
was like oh she's like one of the most
[__] objective judges there is and
she not only not only has she been on
the federal bench but she's actually
been a a [__] def def a public
defender which is really [__]
important honestly I don't think that we
should be allowing people to be judges
if they've never been a public defender
ever like we shouldn't be doing that we
should they should have to have that on
their resume to defend people as a
public defender I think it's really
important cuz it really does a public
defender knows
the mechanisms in court more than anyone
else because their case load is so
[__] heavy cuz most people can't
afford a [__]
lawyer but you get to have one it's a
thing in this country like if we don't
if you don't have the resources for
attorney we will provide one for you
like it's right there you know what I
mean it says it if you don't have uh an
attorney we will provide one for you so
I think judge chuin in the from the very
beginning when I went to look at who she
was and her history I was like oh well
[__] this is the perfect judge for this
case now I said in the beginning that
she was going to piss a lot of liberals
off because she was actually going to
actually give some favor that it seemed
to Trump and that's because judges give
favor to defendants they do because
there are two sides of a case there is
the defense and there's the plank plank
or or the or the the prosecutor in this
case cuz it's criminal there's the
government the prosecutor and the
defendant so there are two sides of a
case and chuin is really aware of that
as a judge and not just because she is a
judge because she has experience in it
I'm super excited that judge chucken is
the is the judge on that case I think
she's going to piss you off I think
she's going to piss so many anti Trump
people up oh my god when she when it
comes down to March 4th and she has to
move this trial and she picks a date
that seems so far away from March and so
far into the election only because
that's the date that makes most sense
for her
court it's GNA piss you off and you're
gon like what the [__] we hate what the
[__] and that whole Twitter is gonna
lose their [__] minds and maanga is
going to be laughing at you because
you're losing your minds Because You
Love now you hate her because she made
an objective decision because I'm
telling you I'm telling you right now
there's one thing that is very clear
about chuin is she's going to make a
decision that is not going to be [__]
overturned in an appeals court that is
her [__] goal because she knows
almost every decision she makes is going
to that appeals court okay she knows
that's what they're going to do not one
because it is Donald Trump he's a whiny
little [__] but because they are trying
to delay and that's the thing you have
to understand is chetkin is going to
make decisions that's best for the
operation of her court because that's
what her job is intended her job is not
to put Trump in jail that's not her
job that's not her
job her job is to oversee the process of
the trying of Donald Trump because he's
been indicted by a grand jury and and
the prosecution brought those grand jury
charges to
indictment that's what her job is and
it's going to make you
mad it's it's it's I mean it's going to
make you mad but I've been telling you
this whole time to give you that
expectation that you shouldn't worry
about that March 4 date you really
shouldn't focus in on that because if
you focus in on that you're going to
lose where you should focus in on where
Grandpa Hitler is telling us that he his
his
[__] his whole
policy no matter what it is is
Revenge you're going to miss out on that
so clip is still trying to get with us
here it looks like he's he's there I
just want to see if make sure he keeps
having some issues here clip give me a
thumbs up if you think you're good okay
all right let's let's do let's do this
let's do this it's live do it live [__]
it we'll do it live we'll do it live
Cliff sha to everyone Cliff how are you
I mean doing [__] great except for
the fact that I just spent like a couple
Grand on this new [__] Studio here
with the beautiful lights and the new
camera and all this [__] and of course
the first time I come in here you know I
get the camera hooked up to my computer
and like my my face is blank which some
people may enjoy more but my face is
blank on your on your no no everyone
everyone wants to see Cliff that's why
wanted to wait until you were on camera
so you're using your cell phone right
now is what I'm That's it man this is
what we call problem solving right now
everybody that's right sometimes
sometimes you just have to go back to uh
the old technology they're saying your
volume's a little low let me see if I
can get your volume adjusted here let me
turn turn it up too no I I think I think
I got you uh I think I got you there uh
so uh I think that'll help everyone oh
man I can scream you know that I can
yell really [__] loud I mean I was
all excited I get to come on your show
like you know I got my new setup here I
got my Bud Light hat on which you know
is both uh it's it's uh did did Kid Rock
send you that did Kid Rock send you that
hat did he send you that hat yes after
he machine guned it it tastes great it's
less filling uh and it has the side
effect of making flaccid Republicans uh
go into a spinning uh like fit of rage
to the point of where they soil their
depends so I find that when you think of
those three things Bud Light is good yes
it is I got a good but light story for
you that I'll tell you but big step fan
says good thing Cliff can cuss on this
show everyone can cuss on this show
everyone can cuss on this show there's
no holes bar so here's my story you know
when the whole Bud Light thing was going
on I went to like a music festival and
there was a bar close by and it was
really busy cuz a lot of people were in
the street you know it was a big music
festival and we went and I went into
this bar and I went up to the bar and I
ordered a Bud Light and a guy standing
behind me he said oh what do you what
you order do you order a skirt with that
beer and I turned around and I said do
you think do you think this beer makes
you gay and he's like what and I said do
you think drinking Bud Light makes you
gay and he's he's like well I just you
know he started in his he just he just
started in his bigoted rant you know
what I mean and then I I finally got my
beer and I took a big old Swig and I
looked at and I said man I can't wait to
get out there and [__] those boys and I
just walked up you should have seen a
look on his face you should have taken a
SG and then maybe stuck your tongue out
and be like oh my God hot tonight all
right I'm gonna try one little thing
here what what are you gonna do you
gonna turn oh there you go look at that
look at look at clip look at clip with
his with his technology Look At Me On
The Run put yeah well you know this
happens this happens I mean this is a
guy who got like a D in high school
chemistry okay like I'm not a a
scientifically line person the only
reason why I passed uh biology in high
school in the first place because I
cheated off someone the entire time so I
respect that I mean the the entire time
I know nothing about biology because I
didn't do any of it so people in my
family we can write and we can talk we
can't do much else so you know
you youti with what you know with the
[__] that works for you you know what
I'm saying so so there's a bit of news
over the weekend over the holiday
weekend um and
and I i' I've been on vacation meaning I
haven't been paying too much attention
but I I wanted to keep enough attention
of to some things apparently Trump
smells I don't know how that's big news
I really don't I don't understand
that I don't understand how Trump smells
as big news because it's been trending
for like four days right I've never the
dude could nuke a country and it
wouldn't trend for as long and be like
okay looks it seems like the levels of
radiation are have gone down
to where they're only five times what we
can accept for human life uh existing
there and it'll be gone in three days
off Twitter but Trump stinks Trump
smells Trump smells bad diaper Dawn
these things have been trending I I mean
every time I put a new video up and try
to get it more views like I hashtag 47
different Trump smells like [__] like
hashtags fantastic so so I actually
found a um a clip and I think it's from
like 2015 2014 14 it was it was right as
Donald Trump was uh was thinking about
running or there was talk of it Charlie
sh Charlie Sheen was on uh Graham
Norton's show now Graham Norton is it's
it's not here in America but a lot of
people like to watch it because a lot of
American celebrities are on that show um
but Charlie Sheen is telling a story
about Trump and he's telling a story
about Trump how uh Trump gave him his
cuffing at like a party for a wedding
gift gift in which Charlie Sheen did not
invite Trump and wasn't going to invite
Trump trump just said I can't make it to
your wedding so here and then months
later Charlie Sheen is getting jewelry
appraised at his house and he has the
appraiser look at these cuff links that
are stamp I bet it's like fool's gold or
something was it so so the quote from
Charlie Sheen is in its in its best day
this is this is the cheapest peer and
the worst Z zonas that I've ever seen
and it's Trump stamped and it's stump
[__] and
and Charlie Sheen goes on to say and he
said you know makes it seem like these
are are Harry Winston you know Platinum
you
know just Flawless diamonds is the way
that Trump sold it to Charlie when he
gave him to him and Charlie's quote was
and it's just a bag of dog [__] it's
just a bag of dog [__] and literally
that describes Trump perfectly it's just
a big bag it's yes it it's it looks
fancy yeah it's got the [__] name on
the building sure they look like
diamonds sure right now it looks like
Platinum but it's just a big bag of dog
[__] and I have to say with Trump
smelling or Trump smells trending that's
what I actually think that he would
probably smell like is a big bag of
fiery dog [__] what do you think what do
you think he smells like oh I think
that's right I mean you you sort of put
it out there your explanation was
perfect
which is the entire existence of trump I
mean this is why it's fun to talk about
because we laugh at him but it's the
perfect metaphor for him the entire
existence of trump is creating an image
that has absolutely nothing to do with
reality like you're fired I ran five
businesses into the [__] ground was
handed $400 Million by my dad and blew
it all and could not run a [__]
Casino where people give you money they
hand over money they they intentionally
lose it to you we get them drunk on free
drinks we don't we have there's no
daylight in casinos so you don't know
where you are you're disoriented there's
no clocks they pump oxygen in and they
just everything to get you to hand over
your money and he lost money on that so
there's that there's the oh you know the
the guy with the women and the whatever
and you find out he's either paying for
them paying them off sadly raping or
molesting them like none of that is is
reality either everything about him is
this shiny rapper and then you find out
he is the cheesiest most gudy gross
disgusting low class slob I mean they
base the Biff Tannon character in Black
to the Future too on Donald Trump that's
who he's supposed to be you know so I
mean he he's just repulsive in every way
and he always wanted to be this Society
guy in New York and society's always
like you're [__] gross and so this is
just to add this to everything else the
fake businessman fake president fake
Ladies Man fake this fake that and and
now it's like he puts on these ill suits
that he that probably he pays he may
even pay decent money for I don't know
but they don't fit him he can't get a
[__] suit to fit him his tie I'm
sorry I had to go to a Episcopalian
School 10 years and tie my own ties Ty
goes down below his dick he doesn't even
know how to tie a tie he looks like this
he looks like a clown with his [__]
suit falling off and now we find out
also that while all that's going on he
smells like abjectly smells like dog
[__] and the beauty of all this is that
it all came out because Adam kinzinger
just threw out a tweet like a week ago
talk about revenge I think Adam
kinginger has now successfully gotten
his revenge for losing that house seat
um you know he he he sent out a t he's
like I'm kind of shocked that none of
the people who've been around Trump you
know who can't stand them now or
whatever have mentioned the the odor you
know he's like it is really something to
behold and that set it off and then your
friends my friends over at Midas had you
know I think it was n castler talk about
it and he was on that show and then he
went and and gave like a three minute
exposition
on the reason Trump smells like [__] and
killed us more with I don't know NL
seems like a nice guy but but I'd like
to ask him please don't ever tell us
that like there was more there than I
ever needed to know um but the why and
then it just took off from there and
like it's been a Non-Stop conversation
and I I'll say one more thing I'll take
it back to you which is here's where
I'll put on my hat as a you know long
time guy political consultant and worked
on presidential campaigns and strategy
whatever the thing Democrats have never
understood as well as Republicans we've
gotten a lot better we got some people
some Goldman's and swells and you know
Stacy plasket and people like that but
they've never understood is the power of
viral moments in today's uh media but
also the power of mockery in today's
media if you can mock somebody and get
that to go viral you can destroy them in
a way that an attack on their policy
positions will never accomplish and so
as much as like Donald Trump should lose
because he's a seditionist [__]
he's a guy that tried to overthrow our
country he's a guy who stole National
Security secrets and probably shared
them with Putin allegedly I'll say in
case anybody's thinking about suing me
he's a guy you know he's he's he's a guy
who you know obviously complete fraud
when it comes to his his properties uh
rape when it comes to EG and Carol and
numerous other women like we can go on
and on about everything that's wrong
with this man but in the end it may be
the thing that beats him is that he
smells like [__] because that's our
country that's that's how we do politics
in this country right well I I mean
that's that that ain't a bad that ain't
a bad uh that ain't a bad point is that
literally the hashtag Trump smells May
save our democracy um because it's the
[__] truth and really you can look at
him and know I I mean I just I can't
imagine that like when he walks in a
room you don't know that he's not there
like it's got to smell like Fu big Mac
sweat Aquanet um [__] Foundation like
literally how much [__] makeup the
guy wears is just overwhelming and then
another guy who was on his show I'll
just say quickly I it's rough but pen
Gillette who famously about how horrible
he was described his hair as piss cotton
candy so there's that to the sticky
gooey gross yellow like he swirls it
around like you know because he has to
cover the 87 different bald areas so he
like swirls the hair you know you know
he's got a left flap and a right flap
right yeah like he's got he literally
has embedded in his head a left flap and
a right flap so and and that's the like
fly or something like what well I mean
normally people would get flaps to fly
but Trump has flaps to look like he has
hair and he's had flaps for a long time
and he has he's he's had it done he he
has gender reconfirming surgery Trump
has
transition to where he's at now can you
imagine doing that much to yourself to
just look human like even look good it
doesn't even look good it doesn't even
look good the Charlie Sheen not Charlie
Sheen the U the Tom Cruz mask from
Vanilla Sky and just that on walk around
like that or one of those masks from
from you know the movies where they
break in your house everybody kills each
other right I can't think of the name
you know what they
made scream too I was thinking of the
ones where
allowed to murder there's one day we're
all allowed to kill each other I can't
think of the you know the pur thank you
yes like they all wear those weird masks
oh there's there's going to be a ton of
purge memes now in the Discord uh
because do that's the thing is is that
that couldn't cover up the smell so I
don't know what he maybe you should just
go and get like an entire bottle of
cologne and pour it down the back oh you
you know that he uses too much colog too
right like he's farting and he's
flatulent and he's scared he's going to
[__] in his diaper so the guy and he's
got he's got a thousand different scents
on him because again he's using all
these different products I think odet is
the strongest scent right so so you know
the guy is and and he's probably
honestly he's not using cologne he's so
trashy he's probably using Axe Body
Spray and he uses like a whole [__]
can a whole can of that [__] I bet he
lays his suit jacket down I'm not
kidding you I bet he lays his suit
jacket down and just [__] just soaks
it in axe uh uh body Flor and you know
he can't actually roll himself over so
probably just roll him over back and
forth in the in the ax body spray suit
right right 100% 100% the guy the guy
tries to cover all his sents with Axe
Body Spray now it's hard for him to
cover his lunacy I don't know if you're
paying attention to this you had
mentioned it the guy posted um on true
social this little graphic here now this
is um what some refer to as a word cloud
okay um and it's the word cloud for
Donald Trump now there was one done for
Joe Biden to and I guess the big word in
Joe B what would Joe Biden do as the
President of the United States for this
work Cloud was nothing that was the
actual word but is this a word cloud
based on what everybody is saying or
like couple like four mag incels
masturbating but but does it matter
because here's the thing is Joe Biden
said nothing Trump said Revenge I would
much rather have nothing than revenge
like honestly it sounds weird that that
that this even exist that their nominee
is their main work CL platform is
Revenge with dictator just tells you
what it tells you is uh he's worried
right now whether he should be or not
about losing to Nicki Haley because he
needs the angriest most vengeful vicious
cruel you know just the worst of Maga to
turn out for him uh because otherwise
that Revenge thing in the middle there
that's not a general election message
that's a 35% in a general election
message you know what I'm well and then
and then the word underneath it
dictatorship and then dictator um power
right uh America which like Revenge
being a dictator to America this stuff
is like wild stuff that no other
candidate in the history of being
candidates would ever ever post this on
her social media but this only tells you
that the um because you mentioned it
earlier when you when you said that New
York cast him out the the elite the
elites cast him out because he's just
white he was never in the famous story
is his dad started of course was a slum
Lord and started these lowincome places
where he was racist and wouldn't allow
people in who were black and used our
tax dollars to build and tax dollars
ripped people off did everything that
his son his son is you know is perfect
fits the dad perfectly and he you know
and he would like the stories are he was
in Queens he would gaze across the water
you know to Manhattan and dream of like
being a big shot there that's why it
hits him so much harder when the when
the Bobby dairos of the world rip the
crap out of him because that's who he
always wanted to be and had NE the
neither the talent smarts or anything to
be that you know and he started off
obviously between third base and home
plate with $400 million handed to him by
Daddy like if he' had any Talent he
could have been a great Builder he could
have been a great actor he could have
been a great whatever with that money
but he couldn't even take that money and
not lose it and turn it into like
bankruptcy you know so and you know
honestly now that you're saying that he
makes a really shitty Hitler too I'm not
gonna lie he makes a really [__] like
like Hitler because I I actually coined
the phrase ninka poop nais like three
years ago ninka poop Nazis and I was
calling them ninka poop Nazis three
years ago and they really are they're
nink poops um but they're Nazis but
they're n poops no but it's perfect
because it gets both parts of the
message in there which is they are evil
and dangerous and they're also buffoons
and that's what Hitler was that's what
EDM mean was you go through any of these
dictators everybody was like that guy's
a buffoon we're okay and then they end
up murdering half a million or six
million or four million people like just
because they're buffoons doesn't mean
they're not dangerous because sadly
there's a lot of buffoons out there who
buy into their crap so I like your your
ning because it gets both parts in there
right and you know the end and the end
thing you know that that works out great
for me but here's the thing is that
they's such ninka poops that I think the
buffoon Hitler would even be
disappointed in them like he would be
like what you're you're you're saying
what like you can't say that out loud
like even Hitler as much as he would say
this [__] out loud and and as fast as he
Advanced from being the guy who is a
national a national socialist right that
the national they love that they
Democrats are
socialist socialist love that right they
always claim the People's Republic of
China right right like they're like oh
China's communist and Trump's like XII
pinging is a Great Dictator he rules him
with an Iron Fist and then they're like
oh it's a republic I have a bank account
over there and I made all of my products
over there and my daughter has like 427
patents over there and you know like
yeah well they hate China until it's
time to do any business and then they
love China well obviously I mean this is
coming from a guy who posted this on his
true social over the weekend and this is
basically supposed to be his platform
now Joe Biden had one but Joe Biden
didn't post it and the reason why is
because Joe Biden could give a [__] less
what the internet says about Jo Biden
doesn't give a [__] he doesn't give a
[__] about what the internet says about
him he's just going to go do his job
he's going to put his shoes on and do
his job and I think that's the whole
point here at the end of the day is
because uh and I want to I want to see
what your opinion is on this 14th
Amendment [__] because mine is very
unpopular in our circles um because I
think it's all [__] and we should
stop doing that stuff because I think
it's a waste of energy it's a waste of
time and the pro-democracy Coalition
does not need a shiny object to distract
from [__] making sure we slam dunk
this guy in the goddamn trash um that's
my opinion but the thing is is that the
difference between Biden and Trump is
really that Americans are like you know
he's yeah Biden's old so it's Trump like
Biden has gaffs at the microphone so
does Trump like this isn't this is not
apples and and apples it's apples and
oranges and it's very easy for americ to
go you know I don't an orange colored
diarrhea right right that smells that
smells like ax body spray and baby
[__] and here's the thing is that here's
the thing is that is that at the end of
the day Americans are going to choose a
steady hand and I and I and I keep
telling uh people around me that are
considering voting for Trump I'm like
look at the end of the day the other
thing that really matters here is that
in 2020 one of the reasons why Joe
Button won is because Wall Street backed
him and Wall Street is GNA do that again
they're going to do that again and the
reason why they're going to do it again
is because they can predict what Joe
Biden's going to do no
CL foreign policy establishment all
these old Republican hands who are
generals and who were at the Pentagon
and whatever who worked for Reagan who
worked for Bush so many of them have
gotten behind Biden it's the same thing
because in the two places and I'm sure
there's others but the two areas of
policy where where you know you you
really really want stability um and not
rash stupid decisions like hey I'm
buying Greenland tomorrow you know and
[__] like that are are the economy and
foreign policy because you give the
wrong messages in either of those areas
and there can be a crash or a war so you
know you're you're exactly right I mean
there's some exceptions there are some
billionaire idiots who just think that
they're safe and they're locked off
compounds as if nuclear waste doesn't
reach them you know uh but but you know
like well the oligarchs the oligarchs
are sometimes the first ones to go in an
authoritarian regime I hate to break it
to the to the billionaires you think
they're safe because Putin killed a
bunch of those sorry he didn't kill them
they just got there were a lot of banana
peels on fifth floor Hotel balconies but
I mean in the end yeah that's what
happens because they're the threats the
people with the kinds of resources that
can take you on are threats I mean and
then you you know like even in his
rotten hell Christmas message that I
found to be very charming and and nice I
thought it was I thought it was right on
point yeah like dude you wouldn't have
made it any easier for us to prove that
you're an [__] like aw but but even
in that like part of what he went off on
you know was like you know when he was
talking about the the people up against
him the crazy this that with all his
madeup words and whatever was the clean
energy nut I'm sorry the the electric
car lunatics and it's like hey Elon you
like your new friend you know I mean
good good good good pick there I'm sure
I'm sure he'll love you if he takes over
again and to make his oil friends happy
suddenly you know I would if I were Elon
and Trump wins I would avoid fifth floor
Hotel balconies how about we put it that
way well here's here's um there's an
official name for it it's called Russian
window cancer is what the uh it's a
terrible disease Perell here on Twitch
says it's Russian window for it folks
one out of every 300 puit suffer are you
suffering are you suffering from Russian
window cancer have you publicly
questioned Vladimir Putin and then
thought with your private military and
then thought you could get on an
airplane that wouldn't crash uh I mean
like I never these people never
understand they're like we'll be it'll
be fine it's like Mobsters you know like
who get in a fight with the other guys
like oh I'll be cool I don't need any
security they're just like okay that's
these Bo nights they're like oh I mean I
know he killed all the other guys just
like me but he wouldn't do it to
me it could it could be this though it
could be an allergy Deb here on YouTube
says allergic to gravity you know that
is a thing you could be allergic to
gravity you know I mean something that
that happens to us that that strikes us
particularly uh if you're unvaccinated
so just keep that in
mind don't don't stand next to fifth
floor window better cut that out I'm
Gonna Get You Banned from oh [__] it
I've been banned before we'll be banned
again it happens here's uh one more
thing that I want to talk to you about
because I seem to have the most
unpopular opinion and I actually don't
think it's a popular opinion I actually
just think that a lot of people are
going with the whole 14th thing because
there's a lot of Talking Heads out there
that um talk about the 14th Amendment
they're cheering it on and I actually I
actually think um at its core is is very
undemocratic and I actually don't
believe that's what the 14th uh section
three says some some believe it does but
if you just read it it's not what it
says at all but here's here's the case
that I want to make uh because there's
several there's several insurrectionists
January 6 Sixers who have been to
federal prison for trying to overthrow
an election on January 6th by going to
the capital and committing violence uh
trying to hang the vice president Trying
To None members of Congress though by
the way some of whom are pretty obvious
conspirators when it comes Scott
Perry they have his phone right I mean
Marg Taylor green gave a speech that's
on video that day whatever go ahead Ted
Cruz Josh hly but here's the thing is
that the the thing that I want from the
14th amends as I'm calling them know um
because it feels it feels like they're
trying to do something that is going to
be done anyways like just leave it up to
the voters just trust the voters I hate
I hate Democratic liberal Elites who who
[__] look down on um most average
working Americans and don't believe
they're going that's right they're not
going to do they're not going to do the
right thing but here's the thing is that
I want the same energy that they are
giving for the 14th Amendment for taking
Trump off ballots in Michigan or
Colorado where what whatever states that
that still remain because a lot of them
Dro their cases I want them to bring the
same energy for the city count the
people who are running for city council
for school boards uh for for State reps
uh I want them there's there's people
who are convicted and went to prison for
the January 6 inter Direction who are
running for congress I don't know if
people know this and and the 14th
Amendment people specifically I pick on
him a lot because I know him I know he's
a friend of yours Glenn kersner because
I would love to have him on like I know
with this actually here's what I should
say Glenn follows me I follow him I feel
like we've we've like we've traded
messages on Twitter I've never met him
never talked to him so again I I talked
to Glenn on camera before and I've had a
good conversation with Glenn but here's
the thing here's the thing is that I
think the [__] sheep food for for the
Liberals where they're feeding sheep
food meaning they're getting everyone's
hope up about the 14th Amendment cuz it
really is hope that they're trying to
sell not the 14th Amendment CU if they
really were grounded in the principles
of the Constitution they would be
talking every day about all the
insurrectionists that are running for
all these offices around the country
because the only there's only one one
instance outside of trump only only one
that I can find outside of trump where
this has been done and his name was KY
Griffin the
one oo and a federal judge said you
can't be a commissioner cuz you're an
insurrectionist and they took him out of
office Trump guy yeah exactly now now
how it happened was is that he was
convicted while he held office because
that's actually what the 14th says uh
and the section 3 says um and the
problem that I think they have by
misinterpreting the Constitution because
I think it is a misinterpretation of it
and the Supreme Court is totally going
to side with Trump on this Michigan has
sided with Trump on this
is that he's not charged with
Insurrection he's not I mean we all know
he did but he's not charged with it and
he's not convicted of it and until you
get to that standard we're just not
going to have him to where he's going to
get 14th by a court and the other point
I want to make before I um throw it to
you because I want to hear your opinion
on this is that I think it is so
important because we only get one
narrative we only get one we don't get
two lanes here we get one narrative
Drive narrative should just be that he
poops his pants right I think we could
win on Trump trump smells like baby [__]
but I think I think we could win on that
but here's the thing is that we can't
rely on Jack Smith to save us we cannot
rely on the Colorado Supreme Court to
save us we can't we definitely remember
when Mueller was going to save us right
exactly two impeachments were going to
save us we cannot rely on them to save
us it is us it we are Trump's jury and
if we believe that he's an
insurrectionist then what you should do
is go vote against him and and and
convict him in the court of the public
Ballot Box and we've been doing it time
and time and time again since 2018 I
don't know why everyone's so afraid of
the American people every single
election the Trump election so tell tell
me what what do you think about this
14th thing do you think it is a waste of
energy because that's kind of I'm
getting to where I'm like look not only
are you keep losing but you keep giving
Trump wins about the ballot and about
him running for president but you are
starting to really bolster their
Narrative of election interference it
really is starting to bolster it tell me
tell me what your opinion is I'm gonna
answer you from the best of my ability
as somebody who's not a lawyer on the 14
I'm not either and then no yeah know I
just like to say that because I don't
want to pretend but I'm I'm of I'm of a
couple Minds about it and I can sum it
up very easily yeah one is um is I do I
am glad that we pushed it with Colorado
because I felt like initially for not
for legal purposes for messaging
purposes a top Court in the state said
that this man was an insurrectionist
they said it out loud and it provided
that messaging went across the country
so one I'm glad we did it at that point
two I fully agree with you now that it
is NE the Supreme Court's gonna overturn
it that it will never be they're never
going to keep him off of a ballot we
don't enforce those things any anymore
the one i' like to point out to people
was when when you know in the
Constitution two people cannot be from
the same state for example and run they
didn't want any one state to have too
much power and run for President and
Vice President George W bush lived in
Texas Dick Cheney was living in Dallas
making a know boatload off of halberton
and he literally flew back to Wyoming
where he hadn't spent he spent like days
over like 20 years and reregistered in
his home state of Wyoming and they're
like that's good enough go ahead right
so in the end the T they don't they're
not going to enforce any of this crap so
yes so here my my couple minds of this
is I'm glad we did it initially we got a
ruling that I think the media covered
and and as a messaging that I am an
expert in I I would think uh I thought
it was great to have across the land
have a a top Court declaring and
insurrections now let that [__] go and
move on to everything else because we're
not going to get anywhere with it and
and even if other state courts declare
it the Supreme Court will overturn it
that's where I am well I I do agree that
overturn it now as far as the Colorado
case the thing that I have a problem
with the messaging and The Narrative of
it is Colorado
they're one Jed said he's clearly an
insurrectionist but the presidency isn't
uh an an officer of the United States
which there's different opinions of that
interpretation uh obviously this is all
interpretation of a constitution that
isn't spelled out word for word on every
single issue kind of the point of has
gone out of their way to misinterpret
everything from
gun law know from a hole in the ground
right now now some some of the Liberals
got really wet in the pants and they got
really excited because they use Neil
gorsuch's decision in Colorado as if he
gives a [__] about being a hypocrite
like are really that's the thing that's
the slam dunk you got is Neil G isn't
gonna be a hypocrite get the [__] out of
here right come on you're gonna rely on
that sorry go ahead no no I was going to
bolster your point which is anonin
Scalia had spent his career you know
attacking like
equal rights or I'm trying to remember
what the phrase was and then when it
came to George W Bush in 2000 he's like
he's been deprived his equal rights like
these guys don't these guys they're not
lawyers they're Republicans and robes
they don't give a [__] so it doesn't
matter well the other thing too is is to
to to believe that Neil gor say isn't
going to be a hypocrite on his decision
here is I mean you you weren't paying
attention the last two years on some of
these decisions because they're like no
it's about states rights and then like
well the state doesn't have the right
like which is it does the state have the
right
the last 20 years like I don't think
there's been you know I don't think
there's been an honest you know at all
moderate to Conservative Republican
that's been on these courts since you
know David suder so it doesn't really
matter anymore what you know they have
different shades of right-wing I'd say
from ultraconservative in John Robert's
case over to full-on fascist in Thomas
Alo and gorsuch's case but who the hell
cares like in the end they're all
political operatives in robes that's
what the feral societ is about that's
what judge eileene Canon is she's a
[__] but she's a political operative in
a robe so to think that they're going to
come to or that that jack off who who
you know got rid of you know Plan B you
know out in Texas like they're not these
are not people that that you know or the
guy in Texas right the one that had been
to all these anti-choice rallies
attacking abortion and then decides this
woman can't have an abortion and acts
like he he's not conflicted out like
they're not that's what the rights
project that Federal Society the last 30
years has been as evil as the NRA or any
other organization they have stacked our
courts with politicians these are
right-wing Republican politicians so
don't think because they have a
precedent that means [__] to them or
they've said something
before like well the other thing too is
even if they have said [__] before and
they want them have a different opinion
Harland Hitler the guy who has a signed
copy of mine c will just you know buy
him a luxury vacation or send him out on
the yacht or you know whatever I mean
apparently the only judges in the
country that can receive gifts are
Supreme Court Justices and that is my
opin for why it is a waste of time at
this point I think I do the only part I
disagree with you I'm glad I did
Colorado because I I do think that got a
lot of press and sent a message but let
it go now because we're never gonna keep
this guy off the ballot in any way like
that let him be on the ballot and let's
kick the [__] out of him well you know I
and I welcome descent here and
disagreement here I'm I'm not scared to
defend my position and the reason why I
thought that this Colorado Supreme Court
decision um didn't help narrative and
the the one reason why is because it
reads in part that they didn't even want
to make the decision it was a 4-3
decision first off and they said look we
really don't want to make this decision
so what we're going to do is act like
we're making the decision and we're
going to make the Supreme Court make
this decision because they put an
immediate stay on it the ballots are
gonna be ported on January 5th so so go
ahead you go sorry no go ahead well I
said I get your opinion I get your point
but to me what you know what we know
which is something that most often hurts
us in this country is nobody read
they just see headlines so I know you're
saying about what the kar Supreme Court
said but none of these folks are ever
going to see that they're going to see
headlines that K Supreme Court kicks
Trump off of off of ballot because of
insurrection so that's and and that's
the problem that I have with it and
that's the problem because here's the
messaging problem that I see with it
because that message is great if he
isn't on the ballot but the problem is
he's going to be on the ballot so the
message is hey we got him off the ballot
and now he's on the ballot and people
are going to go well wait a second I
thought you got him off the ballot like
no no no he's on the ballot like how is
he on the ballot you got him off no no
we actually didn't see and here's the
complicated issue of why we didn't get
him off the ballot because that's what
liberals tend to do H fortunately or
Unfortunately they believe in the truth
and what's real and you know they they
tend to try to explain things and
understand reality right right science
it it is it is sometimes tough to to
construct narratives when you're
Tethered to reality it's so much easier
to construct narratives when you're not
teed to any kind of reality you just
make up whatever [__] you want you just
say it and boy they'll believe it but
when you're trying to tether yourself to
reality it is tough sometimes and that's
why I try to do what I do every day I
know it's what you try to do every day
in the narrative um and I'm so glad that
you're in this fight with us even if we
disagree on these issues a little bit
that's the point that I want to make
this one we probably about 75% agree on
absolutely and and and that's the point
that I want to make to Glenn Kushner
which I call Glenn 2000 he's Glenn 2 um
but I call him Glenn 2000 because I
think he's probably mad at me for having
this opinion but what I want to stress
to him is is stop thinking about the
14th Amendment and start thinking about
this election we need Glenn we need
Glenn in this fight we need cliff in
this fight we need Tony in this fight we
need these people in this fight to beat
trump it is so important that we beat
him it is not so important that we beat
him by 14 in him because we want to use
the consti
it is that we beat him and the easiest
most effective efficient way and that
will a resounding message not just to
him and his MAA cult but all over the
world that we are not MAA America is not
MAA we are not with him we hate that
[__] we do not want him to be
anywhere near our government and we need
to send that resounding message as the
people because we we are Trump's jury
now what I want you to do is to pitch
yourself right now to the audience tell
them where to find you why to find you
there because you got to go follow cliff
and his channel here on YouTube listen I
mean look you said it yourself um I
can't help it I you know sometimes I
wish I could walk away from fights my
parents certainly wished I could at
times um but uh I hate bullies I hate
[__] bullies and that's all the rers
become is about harming people so I go
after them I talk about our positives
their negatives and my messaging
background you know WR I wrote ads for
Biden in 2020 I bring all those
sensibilities plus hopefully a sense of
humor
and a nastiness when it's needed to my
my YouTube channel which it's just you
know seor so youtube.com seor that's
what I'm trying to grow the most I'm not
going bother with Twitter anymore you
can find me on threads at Cliff dor um
but YouTube's the best place so please
come subscribe or having a big
subscription you know try to we're
trying to boost it and really grow in
the next year well I know the mods have
dropped all your links in the chat this
entire time we're talking the audience
loves to have you on I I I know we
weren't on last Thursday and I know you
you're busy tomorrow so I'm glad you
called me and we had you on today and
then hopefully uh next week or the week
after we can get you back on at your
regular Thursday time and we can um I'll
have a guy come in here who actually has
a brain so I won't be a dick and like
have to do it through my phone hey hey
it it worked out perfect it worked out
perfect you're on the show people need
to hear you um and I think it's so
important to have you with us because I
think your narrative is great everyone
go follow Cliff everywhere you can
especially here on YouTube Go go to his
channel find it and I'll be posting more
on a community page you can see him
there as well I try to share the videos
that he shares with our show um because
he does Great Clips of our show too so
thank you clip thanks for being here
thanks for working through the um the
the the the technical difficulties I
appreciate you my friend everyone stick
around we'll be right back don't go
anywhere don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tammy by the time we reached
DC weight was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out that
light hope it don't rain tomorrow so we
can Circle the city again yours Bob dear
Bob I'm fixing to send you some more of
them Doritos you like the red bag not
the live love and blue one in your
absence I discovered a rash on my neck
and no it ain't no hickey and I a even
seen my cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the
show C
Checker
everybody GL to have cliff on
again always appreciate his
perspective even though we disagree
sometimes that's the point we're never
always going to agree like I'm not going
to agree with you 100% of the time
you're definitely not going to agree
with me 100% of the time but we have to
all focus in on what is most important
what is most
important is to have one narrative to
absolutely stomp
Maga into the trash B of History that's
what we have to
do that's what we should continue to do
now I have a few clips that I want to
show you I didn't I didn't do much
social media over the holidays just
enough to try to stay up to speed right
just enough to try to stay up to speed
and then you know laugh a little bit I
had to laugh and one clip in
particular oh my God is um you know this
whole Joe Biden's old Joe Biden this
Biden that and now Biden dur M
syndrome let's go
Brandon all that nonsense you know what
I'm talking about these people lose
their minds over this stuff Joe Rogan is
one of
them and I can't I can't help but play
this clip of Joe Rogan absolutely
getting fact checked by his producer
Jamie live on air it's [__] hilarious
I'm going to show it to you but I do
want to point out a couple different
comments here Jared be says I haven't
heard Tony cough once
today Tony's cough is almost
gone that's what six days of vacation
will do is you rest your voice you just
sit you relax you get
stoned and you
eat smart smart food popcorn I'll get
this I went to Sam's Club right we're
going shopping for like holiday food
and I'm at Sam's Club and there at the
end of the aisle is one of the most
beautiful things I have ever seen in my
entire life it's a big huge bag of
popcorn and I love popcorn and it's
smart
food but it's nacho cheese Dorito
flavored [__] popcorn and I'm like
well I Love Popcorn I love nacho cheese
Doritos they [__] and had a baby and
now I want to eat their
baby maybe I am part of the blood
sucking cabal I want to eat a baby no
I'm just kidding I mean I'm not kidding
I I did almost eat the entire [__]
bag nacho cheese Dorito popcorn cuz I
got stoned several nights in a row so it
just so happens that um I did that um so
that was partly how my holiday was spent
other than resting uh from the cough
from the cough that was was what um I
did I have another couple comments here
um one from Shaz people have been
wondering where Shaz is at oh Shaz is in
the chat act like a dumb [__] so I just
want to point that out um you know we
thought Shaz was actually paid by Ronda
santis to come here and comment on the
show and I actually think he was being
paid um by Ronda santis to come comment
on Facebook because he only comments on
Facebook it's kind of weird it's almost
like he's paid to comment on Facebook or
some [__] but I think I know who he's
paid by no I'm serious I think I know I
think I know what is going on with Shaz
Shaz loves Putin he loves Putin I mean
like four Hearts loves
Putin I don't know I I don't know I
don't know if Shez uh is trying not to
catch Russian window
cancer as prella said earlier prel said
earlier Russian window cancer but Shaz
is trying not to catch that kind of
cancer um so he's really giving four
Hearts to Putin and Russia he really
likes Putin loves Putin loves
Putin seems a little weird Chez I think
he's being paid so I just wanted to get
that little business out of the way
again I also want to remind you that
this week we are on Wednesday Thursday
day and Friday
Friday
Friday so we'll have bonehead of the
week this week and then we'll be off
Monday Tuesday next week for New Year's
and we'll be back Wednesday Tuesday or
excuse me Wednesday Thursday Friday next
week my brain is not fully operational
yet I'm still a little bit in vacation
mode not going to I'm not gonna [__]
you but I wanted to show you this clip
of Joe
Rogan speaking of U brains not operating
here's Joe Rogan and I'm not sure who
this [__] idiot is on his podcast
does it really matter who he is you know
what I was thinking about this too when
I saw this clip and I'm gonna show it to
you I promise but I'm doing the whole
hanger thing big step F's gonna get on
to me over on
U over on Twitch you do this on purpose
Tony you're hanging us yeah yeah I'm
hanging it out there all right so I was
thinking about this clip and I was like
you know what I think I think it would
be fantastic I am a I think it would be
fantastic if I could get on the Joe
Rogan show wouldn't that I mean if I was
invited to Joe Rogan show oh my God I
would [__] be there in a heartbeat
and I would do as many of those shows
that he [__] could stand literally
and I'd sit there for hours just [__]
murdering that [__] IDI OT I'm
serious just one after another after
another after another and alss I would
have to do is just he would say
something dumb and I would look at his
producer Jamie and say Jamie could you
go ahead and pull a clip up that is
totally going to make this [__] idiot
look like an idiot cuz here's an example
of it well you know there's people that
voted for Biden that are doing it now
they're like I what did I do right what
did I choose like how is this guy yeah
you just can't listen to an interview or
he's saying some of the stuff he says
that just makes no sense at all it's
like you can't listen to those
interviews and feel like you made a good
decision I I don't know how you did you
hear what he said like yesterday or a
couple days ago all right so obviously
they're talking about Biden and they're
like oh people who voted for Biden are
regretting that they voted for Biden
because Biden dumb or some [__] like
that you know what I mean that's the
okay
all right have you seen what Grandpa
Hitler's been talking about lately have
you seen that I don't think you've seen
that and it's obvious that they haven't
and they really don't give a [__] even
if they did because listen to this
listen listen to this so talk about the
Revolutionary War he's like one of the
reasons why we lost the Revolutionary
War one of the problems with the
Revolutionary War was they didn't have
enough airports
yeah Joe Biden said the reason why we
didn't RN the Revolutionary War is
because we didn't have enough
airports that's what Joe Biden said he
said that he said that I mean Joe Biden
did say something like that he did say
something like that but it wasn't that
it wasn't that that's not what it was
just watch
watch like pull
him if you were if you had any other job
and you were talking like that they
would go hey you're done if you talk
like that to a doctor at your medical
exam for to fight they' be like okay
like obviously you're not
fighting you would also here's you know
eight weeks of of being helped out by
professional like right you might not
ever do anything again no it's it's it's
one of the wildest Things ever it's
insane and the the media gaslighting you
to protect it's just people are so
afraid of trump being in office and
Republicans being in office you know a
few moments later okay so here's the
premise is that Joe Biden
said airports Revolutionary War he
technically said it he did he did say it
there's a problem though it's a little
problem and the problem isn't that he
said it the problem is is that Joe Rogan
and whoever this other dumb [__] is
totally bought the [__] Facebook post
right they totally bought the [__]
Facebook meme from Farm Fresh Uncle Fred
oh yeah Biden said that [__] do you see
what bid said about airports in the
Revolutionary War what an
idiot and the premise is because Joe
Biden said this okay because Joe Biden
said
this he shouldn't be allowed to be
president okay these are coming from the
same people that are bitching and
moaning of the Colorado supem Supreme
Court decision even though I'm kind of
on their side about it but here's the
point is that they have no tethering to
reality at all it's kind of what me and
Cliff were talking about earlier it's
really
difficult when you got to tether
yourself to reality to get
narrative
spun that's why I do it so well I know
I'm patting myself on the
back but I do it really good and the
reason why is because I don't I don't
mire you in [__] data and polls and
all kinds of [__] historical
historical data shows blah let me show
you a chart you don't need charts to
know [__] okay you don't you don't need
them but what you do need is a [__]
brain and Joe Rogan does not have one
watch this hanging out with the guy I'm
like man well you know it's just the
media narrative I mean so many people
media fault
here's the video here's the video Let's
listen I don't think it
is what by the way the same stable
genius who said the biggest problem we
had in the Revolutionary War is we
didn't have enough
airports
whoa yeah that's it whoa yeah that's it
that's it that's a clip that's a c
that's where Joe Biden said airports in
Revolutionary War in the same
sentence the problem is they weren't
[__] listening they weren't listening
they weren't
listening because they don't listen
because the point is not to listen the
point is to make up [__] in your own
mind to make you a white fragile male
feel good about your toxic masculinity
that's the entire Point here of this
show and it's the point of why people
still watch this
trash it's the entire point listen
masculinity and manliness does not have
to be toxic it doesn't a lot of it is
because a lot of [__] people who
think they're masculine who think
they're manly are [__] toxic as [__]
and it's actually what makes them not
that okay it's what it makes them
not watch as Joe Rogan is shown what Joe
Biden is is actually talking
about what just for for the record is
that fake it's not fake it's real but he
was referencing Trump saying
that oh that's right that's right that's
right Trump said that and and Biden
saying the words airport and
Revolutionary War in the same sentence
when he said because I told you Joe
Biden said that he did say airports and
Revolutionary War in the same sentence
the problem is is that he was talking
about how [__] ridiculous it was that
Donald Trump said that
[__] and he said you're really you're
really going to vote for someone who
didn't know that there weren't [__]
airports during the Revolutionary
War that's what Joe Biden is actually
saying he's actually saying what Joe
Rogan was saying before they played the
clip that's what Joe Rogan was saying is
that if you can believe that [__] you
shouldn't have a job you shouldn't even
be w we shouldn't even be letting you
walk around you should be in some kind
of institution
somewhere but it was Trump who actually
said it and the reason why Joe Biden
said it also is because he was referring
to how ridiculous it was that Trump said
it watch as they get fact checked in
real time and watch what happens when
the cognitive dissidence kicks in you
can see it on their
faces here's what Trump saying it in
2019 Donald Trump said something about
that he didn't say G Jesus he said a
stable genius and that's where the
transcription let me hear what it says
what did he says in June of
1775 the Continental Congress created a
unified Army out of the Revolutionary
forces encamped around Boston and New
York and named after the great George
Washington commander and chief the
Continental Army suffered a bitter
winter of Valley Forge Found Glory
across the Waters of the Delaware and
seized Victory from Cornwallis of
Yorktown our army manned the amp it ran
the ramparts it took over the airports
it did everything it had to do oh okay
yeah oh okay all so he did say
it oh he did he did say it and then and
then the clip that we were talking about
with Joe Biden that I seen on on the
books of
face oh that that was because Trump said
it and Biden was saying it he said it
and he's an idiot for saying
it you would think the response would be
I'm a [__] dumbass what a [__]
idiot I am holy [__] I can't believe
that I believe that [__] that was posted
on social media cuz I'm a [__]
doofus that should be the response that
Joe Rogen has that should be the
response I'm a [__] doofus that I
believe that [__] I got duped by social
media and a bunch of [__] dumb asses
on social media to believe that Joe
Biden said that [__] not Donald
Trump because Joe Biden did say it when
he was referring to how ridiculous
Donald how ridiculously stupid it was
when Donald Trump said that [__] and
that you shouldn't let that guy be in
[__] office especially in the highest
office in the land the president of the
United States when he doesn't even know
that there weren't airports during the
Revolutionary
War so you think Joe Rogan here would
have that same stance at this point that
he had for Joe Biden that Trump should
not be in for for office but listen to
what you can see it you can actually see
it you can see the cognitive dissidence
happen watch this [__] him and whoever
the [__] chucklehead who's sitting
there with him watch the cognitive
dissonance wash over their face
watch so he [__] up yeah he did but I
feel
like you could tell to it sounds like a
little different he's like you could
tell he like messed up his words but
yeah yeah he just I don't know to go
over the air force there you go watch it
again what see if you can spot this the
cognitive dissonance it's incredible
watch their faces so he [__] up yeah
he did but I feel
like you could tell too it sounds like a
little different he's like you could
tell he like messed up his words but
yeah yeah he I don't know to go over the
airport well that's the thing about
that's the thing about media these days
it's like right oh it's the media's
fault it's the media's fault that I'm a
dumb [__] it's the media's fault that I
don't check into
[__] it's the media's fault that I just
believe anything I [__] see because
it makes me feel good oh pull it up
Jamie that's what I keep telling you
about the 14th Amendment [__] don't
believe that [__] just because it makes
you [__] feel good about the March
4th trials going to happen on March 4th
no matter what it makes you feel good it
makes you feel good okay makes you feel
good that's all it means that's all it
does and if you're looking for a [__]
uh a political orgasm a plasm I guess we
would call it there's a lot of other
things that you could be
doing I mean porn is free on the
internet if you're looking for you know
an exciting time and and there's porn
all over the internet and it comes in
all different forms and Fashions
Fashions if you're looking for an
exciting time to just you know be happy
and stuff but here's the thing don't in
in a
world of Joe Rogan's be a Jamie would
you be a Jamie okay just go look at it
and look at and go oh okay he's talking
about that that and that so that's what
they're talking about oh I see I I see
why why I'm getting out of Step because
me not being fully Tethered to
reality makes it to where I make My
Views based on what makes me feel
good and have a political orgasm I think
I just coined that phrase did I just
coin that phrase a political orgasm I
don't know definitely zero days since we
talked about porn uh for
sure we talked about political orgasms
and Tony eating
babies what what what was the Tony
Michaels podcast about today well he had
Cliff Shar on and then he talked about
how he likes to eat Nacho Cheese
flavored babies and he likes to at
political orgasms where else are you
going to go you're not going to go
anywhere else and get this kind of [__]
no hell to the no where the [__] else
are you going to go you can't go
anywhere and get this kind of
commentary you can't you won't dare you
if you will try I dare you all right
speaking in cognitive dissonance I would
be derel to my duty if I did not show
you this video of this wild ass Trump
supporter and I think this is in Iowa I
really do think this is in Iowa um I'm
I'm pretty sure it's in Iowa where this
lady is at some kind of [__] rally or
Nazi Rally or some [__] there um
it and it really it really is disturbing
like to watch some of this and some of
the [__] she says like you're just like
what in the
[__] you know you know there's a lot of
conspiracy theories out there about [__]
in your water you like like in
Chemtrails Alex Jones wants to talk
about Chemtrails and like fluoride in
your water and [__] and how it's
brainwashing people and stuff you know
I'm not going to say that those
conspiracy theories are real because
they sound stupid as [__] but you do
have to wonder
where some of this [__] [__] comes
from now I'll tell you where it comes
from it stems from mental illness in
this country and we don't actually have
a mental health system in this country
like we need mental health care and we
need it [__] bad like quick fast and
in a hurry and it is clear that we have
a mental health problem in this country
and the reason why we have a mental
health problem isn't because we got a
lot of people running around with mental
health problems that's one of the issues
but it would be nice if we actually
helped those folks with mental
illness really would we're like the
richest [__] country on Earth
everyone's got mental illness at some
point in their life to some degree they
really do because I I I'm not I'm not
honestly I have mental health problems
I've had therapy before I've went
through therapy there's a lot of things
that I think about that I'm I'm like
really did that [__] me up or did it not
[__] me up I mean I'm [__] up look at
me look at I I'm talking about eating
nacho cheese flavored babies and
political orgasms of course and not all
that it's a little [__] weird but we
all are okay we all we all have illness
that we deal with especially mental
illness at some point in our life to
some
degree and the problem is is we as a
country have ignored that mental health
infrastructure we just cast them out as
some lunatic on
Facebook and that's kind of where this
uh this lady lands is like ah she's just
a [__] lunatic who reads Facebook too
much the problem is is she's got
something that ain't right that that
needs
help and she's being fed propaganda
knowing that she ain't right and she
needs help and that she's easy to
convince of dumb stupid
lies and that's how they got their cult
together the
Republicans that's what the entire
Republican Party in the bases
is it's a bunch of people walking around
with untreated mental illness and they
have no clue because most of the time
mental illness is invisible right I mean
sometimes it's not invisible sometimes
it's very [__] visible that someone
isn't
right but most times it's very invisible
and and we we deal with it in different
ways right now this is a very deep
conversation this isn't like nacho
cheese Dorito baby type conversation
it's a very deep
conversation and because it goes to the
core of our country and it really is
what is causing this disease of fascism
to
spread really is because we actually
don't have the mental
health Healthcare infrastructure in this
country
to deal with this problem we don't so
the last thing we should do is elect
people who absolutely don't want us to
have health care anyways forget about
mental health care because they feed off
people who have mental
illness that's who the the fash target
they target people who have mental
illness problems in that moment or long
term and there's all sorts of different
[__] mental illness that's one reason
why it's a troubling thing is because a
lot of times you can't see it it's
invisible it really is an invisible
illness this ladies is not so invisible
watch the crazy stupid ridiculous stuff
that she says tell me about the shirt
you're wearing I pretty much speaks for
itself is that something you would
really like to see happen absolutely
even with that crucifix dangling over it
what would Jesus think of that
absolutely he's been he's not just a
Trader now he's been a Trader for
decades everybody so
Jesus the guy that was crucified on the
cross wow I don't know if they know she
she clearly has no clue what the cross
even
means she doesn't know that that was the
device used to torture
Jesus that was his
punishment that was his hanging
in other
words she thinks
Jesus would be for hanging Joe
Biden I almost bet that this this lady
is was raised in a church in this
country almost better her entire life it
may be one of the reasons why she has a
trauma that she's dealing with maybe I
don't
know it's clear that this this lady
could really take advantage of a mental
health care infrastructure in this
country that would provide her a way to
deal with whatever trauma she's dealing
with but she clearly does not understand
what the second half of that book that
Donald Trump held upside down after he
gassed protesters to march to a church
she clearly does not understand what the
second half of that book says but let's
keep going but he knows it but but again
you have Jesus hanging over hang for
Biden would Jesus be cool with it what's
the penalty for treason
death um tell me this then put him in
prison for the rest of his life uh so
what is it about Donald Trump forgetting
Joe Biden for a moment that you like so
much what did he do for this country
what did he do for the entire world
world peace Lord gas prices taxes
everything everything was phenomenal
under Donald Trump none of that none of
that is true none of that we were still
in a war in Afghanistan from the time
Donald Trump came in the office until he
left Joe Biden actually got us out of
Afghanistan that's the only war that we
have boots on the ground for when When
Donald Trump was president that was the
only war that we had boots on the ground
for it's the only War since that war
that we've had boots on the
ground our troops are not serving in a
hot War they were in Afghanistan under
Donald Trump
Donald Trump did not lower gas prices
because a president doesn't lower gas
prices it's not what a president does
the
market lowers them and sometimes it's a
bunch of crooked [__]
controlling the market like gas prices
are going to go up here
soon because they're going to stop the
flow of
oil they're going to stop production
which causes a lower Supply which in
economics when you have a lower Supply
creates a higher demand for that Supply
which causes the price of it to rise it
inflates how these things
work the problem is is this person
doesn't clearly understand these easy
things um K here points out that she has
Charlie Manson eyes again folks that's
why I believe that this person here we
we as a
country we as a country have failed each
other we have failed each other
badly and we have failed her we have
failed this person and I know it feels
like she's lost and we should mock her
which I mean this crazy [__] she says we
should but folks this is an a prime
example of how we have failed this
country so badly that these people are
willing to believe outright lies that
just aren't even on their face anywhere
near
reality and it's why it's so
easy for them to believe fascism
everything was everything everything
absolutely everything was and now
it's what is bad right now specifically
to you everything's bad look at all the
wars going on everywhere gas prices but
do you blame do you blame President
Biden for the for the wars that are
going on absolutely and the Democrats
and
Obama Obama calling the shots right now
it ain't Biden
Biden's so it's Obama calling the shots
I believe so what did he say at the end
of his second term or after his second
term he said if he could have a third
term and have a bug in someone's ear and
run it from his basement that's that
would be good enough for him and I
believe that's what he's
doing
but this person loves Trump who says he
wants to be a
dictator uh Joan says uh she's a white
Christian nationalist this this lady May
uh uh dispe White Christian nationalism
and I'm telling you she is saying this
she is believing this [__] she is puking
it up here on what appears to be a
sidewalk outside a Nazi
rally but she doesn't know what white
Christian nationalism is no clue not a
clue she has no clue about her
ideology she doesn't
know her mental illness is way in the
way of all of
that way in the way of all of that and
really it's an exploitation of white
Christian
nationalists on this lady that is the
problem like that's what's really
happening is they're exploiting these
ble people they're exploiting their
mental health problems that are go un
[__] un [__] cared
for and honestly if we had our our each
other's backs in this country more than
we
do because you know um a lot of people
want to write off R people a lot of
people a lot of white white Christian
white nationalists want to write off
black people or brown people in this
country oh they're the bane of our
existence they're taking our
jobs
what what do you mean they're taking
your jobs so go get a job well I can't
find a job well what are you talking
about well unemployment's bad you can't
get anyone to work there's no
help it's so dumb it's such [__]
crazy ass lies but these people believe
it and they exploit these people listen
to more of this [__] that she pukes up
off her Facebook page because I hadn't
heard that Obama's running the white
house before is there sort of support
for that that you've heard Biden's not
doing it but is there support for that
that you
heard he's
incompetent Biden is incompetent I mean
he shoots himself and when he goes to
see the pope and everywhere else and he
has no idea where he's at most of the
time or what he's doing find his way off
a stage you mean when he tripped over at
what at the military thing many times I
mean he's like
uh none this would be happening if they
hadn't stolen the 2020 election from
Trump and we the people that's a fact
they stole the 2020 election and none of
these wars would be going on there would
still be World Peace had they not stolen
the election from us and Donald Trump in
2020 do you blame the Biden
Administration for both of the wars that
are going on the Middle East and in
Ukraine B Administration the Democrats
the Rhinos yeah even though it was Putin
who went into Ukraine and it was Hamas
that went into he would have never done
that if Trump was in office like he
should be
okay and then stolen election what's the
evidence of that that you're pointing
mounds of evidence are you serious right
now there's mountains of evidence in
some states Biden or Trump was way ahead
and then the within seconds in front of
your eyes all of a sudden Biden's ahead
and Donald Trump is behind by 30,000
votes I mean it's like 30,000 votes were
taken away from Trump and given to Biden
I mean right that not just be counting
votes mail in ballots remember that was
the pandemic election right okay this is
same old story but this is what I said
earlier like this 14th Amendment alls it
proves really the silver lining in the
14th Amendment nonsense that I don't
like and I think we should stop that
[__] um the the silver lining in that is
it's proving that Democrats had no way
to rig the 2020 election like if they
can't even [__] figure out a way to
keep him off a ballot I mean if they
just wanted to they just didn't don't
have to print his name right because
they don't give give a [__] they don't
care they'll cheat to win you know that
sort of [__] right but their logic
doesn't break through reality keep going
this gets a little crazier I know you're
like what the [__] but here it is the
pandemic you mean what do you mean it
was released intentionally that's what I
mean remember we heard this [__] purpose
so they could use ballot stuffing and Oh
So Co they released Co so they could
stuff the ballots yes absolutely it was
a pandemic everyone knows that it wasn't
just a fluke a bat got out
of it was planned it was
planned everyone responsible for it
should be at the end of a noose or in
prison the rest of their life right
along with fouchy and everyone else that
was involved if you could have an option
of four years of you know what funny
about fouchy Donald Trump gave fouchy an
award his last day in office gave an
award for his work on Co hm wonder how
she feels about that she probably do
know about that Donald Trump as a
dictator or four years of Joe Biden as a
president what would you here it is
Donald Trump there it is as a dictator
he wouldn't be a dictator no no but I'm
in in this silly hypoth Donald Trump I'd
still say Donald Trump y absolutely no
you know who the dictator is right now
Biden Biden and look at the [__] that
they're doing to Trump in
court they have no grounds for any of
the stuff that they're taking him to
court for it's all Bullit to keep him
from being able to run in 2024 for
president they're trying to give Donald
Trump the death penalty for some
[__] charges it's crazy I haven't
heard the death penalty to Donald Trump
actually I've only heard that possible
prison time some some of them just fines
what for what well I mean they there
they violations of laws in Florida and
in Georgia and federal so why didn't
they bring these charges up up against
them when they happened if if they're so
bad you know I'm not I'm not in the
Justice part I don't know because
they're scared to death of him and
they're trying to keep him from being
able to run for president because they
know they're going to lose unless of
course you know they cheat again like
they did in 2020 I don't think they
thought they cheated but I think that
they know they cheated everyone knows
they cheated everyone in their dog knows
they cheated and stole the 2020 election
it was hey hey hey hey hey hey easy
everyone even even everyone's dog hates
Ted Cruz okay dogs don't know about
elections they just know they hate Ted
Cruz and if you want to get some even
your dog hates Ted Cruz merch don't
forget to go to the dony michaels.com
that's the dony michs that's as good as
the grift I'm GNA get even my dog ate
stick Cru or even my cat ate dead Cruise
it's getting cold outside or if you want
to get a warm cup of cocoa you can get
you even my cat or even my dog hates
take's coffee mugs don't be stealing my
[__] what are you doing just stealing my
[__]
it's it's clear as day but except 60
courts said they didn't I'm I don't have
a horse in the r dirty because they're
dirty but they were Republican courts
and Democratic courts and all sorts of
courts they're
rhinos so unless they agree with Donald
Trump they're
Rhino no I'm not saying they have to
agree with Donald Trump to be a r not be
a rhino there's a lot of rhinos out
there and the Democrats Stick Together
Like
Glue it's just they're scared of him
wooo baby now a lot of people are
pointing out um this lady's eyes okay
they're pointing out that she's not
blinking here's the thing I she could be
on some sort of thing Cynthia says she
doesn't blink right she's like it's it's
that political or orgasm
stuff it's that political orgasm stuff
that's going on do we have a sound bite
for this and remember go ninja go ninja
go go ninja go ninja go that's what we
got to do about this stuff is go ninja
go ninja go against Super Shredder and
his army of
of of foot soldiers these maganga foot
soldiers these buffoons cuz in the movie
of the Ninja Turtle movie m the the foot
soldiers are ninga poops and in the real
life
story maanga are the ninga poop Nazis it
really is it really is um but the reason
why she's not blinking is exactly what I
was saying earlier about a political
orgasm she's high on this stuff folks
she's she's [__] fueled by the hate
she can't help it she's fueled by it and
the the visceral language that her face
Facebook page pumps into her
brain it's what it
is it's what it
is and is she is she someone who can be
saved from this this kind of cognitive
dissonance I doubt
it I doubt it I doubt I doubt she's
savable from this level of cognitive
dissidence that clearly her mental
illness
is snowballed into this
place this dark place where she believes
this
stuff it's sad it's
sad but it's
true the other thing too is she probably
votes she probably
votes and she's going to vote for
someone who's not 14th on the ballot if
you know what I mean
that's right he's going to be on the
ballots whether you like it or not he's
going to be on the ballots in Michigan
and Colorado he's going to be on the
general election ballots and this lady
is going to go vote for him so you got
to ask yourself are you going to stand
there and get all your political orgasm
all hopped up on
[__] or are you going to come back
to
reality and you're going to understand
the risk you're going to understand the
the the actual problem
that we need to solve here and that's
the problem of narrative to make sure
the country knows exactly what they need
to do which is to go vote against Donald
Trump because of wild crazy [__] like
this do it do it do it Go Ninja Go Ninja
Go Play it
again and remember go ninja go ninja go
yeah go ninja go ninja go and don't seek
revenge that's not a good presidential
campaign you shouldn't you should not
try to seek revenge but what you should
do is come here every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube twitch and Facebook now on
Instagram unless I get banned again I
don't know I don't know thanks to all of
you for all the messages that you gave
throughout the holidays I want to thank
you and we're going to go into the new
year we're going to have a show tomorrow
we're going to have a show Friday and
then next week we're going to take
Monday Tuesday off and we'll be on
Wednesday Thursday Friday next week stay
tuned stay
cool same time same place tomorrow surf
sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at@
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
that because your critics keep saying oh
he wants to be Hitler he's talking about
poisoning our blood he's trying to be a
Nazi how do you respond to these people
first of all I know nothing about Hitler
I'm not a student of Hitler I never read
his Works they say that he said
something about blood he didn't say it
the way I said it either by the way it's
a very different kind of a statement
what I'm saying when I talk about people
coming into our country is they are
destroying our country this country is
we have prisoners coming in we have
mental patients coming in by the
thousands really by the millions because
you take a look I believe the number
will be 15 million people maybe more
than that by the time this lunatic
leaves office because your critics
keep
right into the back of a guy Gage
truck